I saw on your Instagram stories you're
singing some Adele yeah and you know
Adele can perfectly rap monster
flawlessly she has a new record she's
just finishing up so I know that you
don't often talk about the
collaborations but is there an Adele
Nicki something could be in the works
would you do it if she asked yes and yes
yes yes
Adele made me swear to secrecy that I'm
not allowed to tell anyone that I'm
working with her and we already shot a
video and it's an epic song Nicki Minaj
congratulations here we are in Beverly
Hills celebrating your collection what
does this mean to you Ben D prints on
Nicki Minaj I am so grateful to everyone
at Fendi my working relationship with
them has just been ideal since the day I
went out there to meet with them I'm
honored of course like it just was like
it's been the the big freaking deal yeah
and I had no idea by saying you know
Fendi and my song that they would then
it would turn into a line but thank God
it did no it turned onto a cultural
phenomenon behind a bra a brand that was
known for one thing back on the map in a
Bueller way congratulations and the
pieces are amazing see what was the
inspiration and how much how much design
time went into making it well we've been
working on it for a couple months
so when I went down there they had some
things that they already planned for
that for the next wave of clothes and I
was like oh well you know I'm Nicki
Minaj we gotta have a pop of pink and
you know so all of the pink you see it's
me going in and begging and saying oh
know we have to you know switch it up so
I wanted to trust their you know opinion
with the metallic that's where they were
organically going and then I felt you
know we can put some some low hood stuff
in it because I didn't want it to feel
too high-end so I put stuff in like
sneakers that felt really like the
sneakers that I grew up wearing and
stuff like that what does it feel like
to have your man sitting beside you
wearing your face on a Fendi shoe right
now couples goals right here and I was I
was I was taping your shirt in the car
like I'm a bad [ __ ] this is crazy
well and you teased in August that we
got the marriage certificate so what's
happening is after this launch now we
have wedding planning time yes but not
the major wedding yet just the actual
marriage you know we've we got the
marriage license now I just have to wait
until my pastor that I love comes and
does it for us okay but um the big
wedding and all that stuff that'll
happen but just not at this moment and I
have someone I'm not gonna say a dope
designer who already said that they're
gonna design my dress and I'm really
excited okay and you're going full bride
like I need you in a princess dress you
know I feel like I am wouldn't I was so
crazy when I was little I always
imagined you know Princess Anne in
marriage and wedding the wedding and now
it's more to me about the life the
future to love the partnership then the
wedding which is so strange because I
didn't expect myself to be one of those
people who didn't care about the hoopla
and I really don't and he was asking me
today too he was like so you know what
are we gonna do it like cuz you keep on
you know I'm like yeah I just I just
kind of feel like it doesn't mean as
much as as it used to mean because the
other part the real part I'm so happy
but that happens when you're at the
right person thank you okay so Kelsey
the you know investigator has done some
sleuthing on Nicki Minaj music we have
been we have the Fendi song yeah okay we
saw a picture of you guys in the studio
on your Instagram yeah and you've teased
a little bit about the five fifth thing
thing is it is that the title we don't
know we don't know okay so what is going
on if I'm doing and I love you I love
you fans I am speaking from the fans
what's going on Nicki what's this music
thing is I'm always working but I just
don't know if I want to technically come
out of my Twitter retirement yes so I'm
working and I'm working and what if I do
put out the fifth thing thing it's gonna
be iconic and inside yeah but I don't
know yet next level Nicki is like what I
like to call that yes now how cool is it
that when things do start on the
internet or rumors you listen you're one
of the most famous women on the planet
people are headlining you every day the
fact that you can go on Queen radio and
say here's how it really went down and
you can talk for hours if you want to
explain the entire story that must be so
revealing and a little bit scary though
at times I was just about to say that
it's it's gotten so big was that
sometimes when I feel like I'm just
there cackling with my girlfriends
it becomes like a major international
headline and I'm like oh shoot wait a
minute I forgot I was talking to a bunch
of different countries yes so the whole
world yeah so now
I'm trying to like curl myself but I
hardly address things so so therefore
when I do address them it all just comes
out like everything comes out and then
I'm like oh but you know what what I
will say on a positive note of how clean
radio is that my fans loved it because
it made them feel reconnected with me
again when I first came out I was like a
major Twitter artist I know what I
always spoke to my fans on Twitter and
now it's like they have a way to speak
to me directly and get my input on stuff
and I get to see them and still I still
know a lot of my fans if I face the name
and Twitter names so I think that's the
good thing is the fact that they feel
connected to me
[Music]
[Applause]